[Mark] Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to "Five Nights At Freddy's: Sister Location".
Now, earlier today,
Scott released a patch for the game
that involved Night Four, because apparently, *SNIFF*
the springlock section was OBSCENELY difficult,
but not for ME, because I beat it pre-patch
and it even said, in the patch notes,
that I get bragging rights. He didn't call me out specifically,
but I know that I was in his heart when he was thinking about it
so I get to keep (Royaliplier) my crown upon my head
and I still, as smelly, and as tarnished, and as slightly sweaty as it may be,
I get to keep my glorious crown,
and continue to call myself...
THE KING...
of Five Nights at Freddy's.
(Weirdly pleased noise) mhmmm
Sorry, did I not say that right?
The ...
(Painlful kingly expression of kingliness) KING!
Ow... of Five Nights at Freddy's.
So I get to be a little proud of that, but I'm sure that my pride will be ripped from my chest
as soon as I go into Foxy's area
because I'm pretty sure there's something NEW
waitin' for me-
I'd better start this thing. *clank*
[Female Robotic Voice] Funtime Auditorium Maintenance Vent opened. [Mark] I bet it's not gonna be Foxy.
*Empty flashes*
*Light recharging*
*Footsteps*
I don't hear nothing,
which is usually a bad sign...
I mean, usually, it's a good sign, but-
*Flash*
*Light recharging*
*Footsteps*
*Marks stressed face*
Is there no one here?!
*Flash*
*Light recharging*
*Footsteps*
*Door bang*
AUGGHH- I guess we're just DONE-
OHHHHH GOD- I DON'T LIKE THAT- OHHHH
[Female Robotic Voice] Motion Trigger: Parts and Service
[Mark] UGGHHHHH- ah
[Hand Unit] Great job reaching Parts and Service.
Mark: Ugh.
Circus Baby has been deactivated for an unknown reason.
It's your job to make sure she is structurally stable and secure to the conveyor.
Our technicians will take it from there.
*Static*
[Mark] Hi...
Hi...
[Baby] Can you hear me?
[Mark] NOOO.
I mean yes, but
[Baby] I'm pretending-
Remember how I said I could pretend?
[Mark] Nn-nn
[Baby] The cameras are watching
I must be careful not to move.
Something bad happened yesterday-
Something bad always happens....
I don't want it to happen again
There is something bad-
Inside of me
I'm broken...
I can't be fixed.
I'm going to be taken to the Scooping Room soon
but it's not going to fix what's wrong with me.
What is bad is always left behind.
Will you help me?
[Mark] Uh-uh.
[Baby] I want you to save what is good
so the rest can be destroyed
[Mark] Ugh
[Baby] and never recovered.
But you must be careful;
Ballora is here *A very confused Mark*
in the room with us.
Ballora will not return to her stage.
Ballora will not return to her body.
You must be careful.
*A very confused bean*
You must remain calm
and listen to my voice.
There is a button on my cheek.
You must find it, and press it.
Mark: What...? *Laughs* Oh, this one?
*Hatch Opens*
[Mark] *Laughs*
*Chuckles* Oh god...
Why is there a key-
[Baby] There is a passcode that you must enter before you can retrieve me.
Enter the code carefully...
Seven
[Mark] Ugh oh, seven
*Beep*
[Baby] One
[Baby] Seven
*Beep*
[Baby] Four
[Baby] Five
*Beep*
[Baby] Seven
[Baby] Two
*Beep*
[Baby] Nine
[Baby] Three
*Beep*
[Baby] Good.
A hatch should have opened.
Take the card that you find inside.
[Mark] Huh?
Huh? Ohhh...
[Baby] Now, you must turn back.
I will guide you through Funtime Auditorium so you can reach the Scooping Room.
When you are there,
I want you to destroy this body.
Put the card into your handheld device
and I can continue to speak to you.
Now
press the green button to your left.
This will send me to the Scooping Room.
[Mark] uhh...
okaYY...?
I thINNNK...?
Ok?
*Machine whirring as Baby goes to the Scooping Room*
[Mark] Goodbye... I suppose...  See ya...
*Machine clunking*
*Machine clanking*
[Mark] What the shit just happened?!
How do I know I didn't take the good stuff to the...
[Baby] You must follow my instructions in Funtime Auditorium. [Mark] Ugh
[Baby] Ballora is going to follow you.
[Baby] She will try to catch you.
[Mark] Oh, ok.
[Baby] I will help you avoid her.
She will not follow you inside the Scooping Room.
She is afraid.
[Mark] Ok...Yeah...
[Baby] Go back, now. [Mark] She was just there but why did you kidnap me?!
Was that the good or the bad?!
Ok...
Alrighty then...
I guess....
[Baby] Go forward.
Stop.
Go forward and left.
*Pitter patter on floor*
[Mark] *gasp*
[Baby] Keep going.
[Mark] Why is it so wet?
[Baby] Stop.
Be silent.
[Mark] *Yells* OK!!
[Baby] Go forward and left.
*Crackling of floor*
[Baby] Stop.
[Mark] So wet...
Why is it wet?...
[Baby] Go forward.
You are almost there.
Stop.
She is right in front of you.
Don't. Move.
[Mark] Unh...
[Baby] He is here to help, Ballora.
He is not here to hurt us.
[Mark] Ugh.
[Baby] Ballora...
He is here to help us.
[Mark] What if I flash my beacon right now?
[Baby] Go forward again.
Ballora is behind you.
She is afraid of the Scooping Room.
She will not follow you.
*Crackling of the floor*
*Banging*
[Mark] Oh god.... I did it...
[Hand Unit] Warning, you've entered a highly dangerous area.
[Mark] Ugh...
You have entered from Maintenance Hatch 1B, reserved for cleaning and repair of the Scooper.
[Mark] Oh no....
[Hand Unit] Entering this side of the room is strictly prohibited by unauthorized personnel- *Static*
[Mark] He-
Wait a minute...
Is-
Is that Ballora's body-
[Ethereal Female Voice] You are in the Scooping Room now.
[Mark] But if-
[Ethereal Female Voice] Funtime Foxy has already been here today.
Funtime Freddy has already been here today.
Ballora has already been here today.
[Mark] THEN WHO WAS IN THE OTHER ROOM?!
[Ethereal Female Voice] Circus Baby has already been here today.
I've been out before
but they always put me back.
They always put us back inside.
There's nowhere for us to hide here.
There is nowhere to go.
[Mark] Ugh.
Ugh
[Ethereal Female Voice] When we look like this...
[Mark] HEY I SEE YOU
[Ethereal Female Voice] But if we looked like you-
[Mark] OH...
[Ethereal Female Voice] Then we could hide.
[Mark] NOO!
[Ethereal Female Voice] If we looked like you, then we would have somewhere to go.
Mark: NOO!
[Ethereal Female Voice] The Scooper only hurts for a moment.
[Mark] NOOO
*Alarm beeping*
AHHH! DON'T SCOOP ME! NOT ME!
*Metal clanking*
AGHHH! Oh geez, I got scooped?!
OH GOD... *chuckling*
Oh no... I knew something was BAD! I knew it was WRONG!
[Little Girl Voice] Don't tell Daddy that I'm here.
[Mark] Huh.
[Little Girl Voice] I wanted to watch your show too.
I don't know why he wouldn't let me come see you-
You're wonderful!
Where did the other children go?
*Dramatic music*
[Mark] Oh geez...
So am I dead- Am I dead? *chuckling* Is that what it said?
*Dramatic music*
Oh geez...
*Dramatic music continues*
Oh god, what is that?
Oh no....*chuckling* OH GOD NO... *chuckling*
Hey handsome, how you doing there?
Oh that's.... Ah
Hi Baby, how are you doing? *chuckling* You enjoying my body? *chuckling* It's very ni-
NOOO
THAT'S NOT THE END
I know it's not the end, I know that's not the end
There's NO WAY in hell that was the end.
Ok, so I'm gonna get through these- I'm gonna get through these credits,  but you know I might- I might as well take this moment to say that this game is phenomenal.
I LOVE it, and a lot of people probably are like comparing it to the old Five Nights at Freddy's
but I think this is exactly what this series needed.
A paradigm shift in what it is while still keeping the creep universe that it's in.
I think it captured like the essence and the feel of Five Nights at Freddy's, as opposed to anything else.
You know, the other ones tried to replicate the formula but this one broke the mold and yet kept the feel of it, which is wonderful.
But this is not done. Scott, I know you. I know this.
It doesn't end in the fifth night. I know that. NOOOOO NO GET OUT OF HERE
GET OUT OF HERE
YOU GET OUT OF HERE
NO WAY
NO NO UH-UH NO NOT HAPPENING
NOPE NOT NO THAT'S A BIG NO
Ok, so there's more to this and I'm gonna explore and try to find it.
So I'll be right- I have a funny feeling. It has to do with those death mini games, because there's probably a way, if you ration your cupcakes correctly,
and assign the cupcake to the right child because some cupcakes, like some kids
only had one cupcake, some kids had multiple cupcakes, so there's a way to do it,
so that there's more.
OH, I get extras now. I see, I got one star. I KNOW THERE'S MORE.
I know there's got to be more. There's definitely got to be more.
OH, look, *chuckling* it's Baby....and her babies....
OH, oh, that's what they were.
They look like little- little- uh- animation drawing figurines.
You know, mannequins.
OH, look at that. They almost look adorable.
Oh ho ho ho ho, she's beautiful.
OH,  *deep breath*, see? See?
OOH OH Aw man, why so many wires? *chuckling* Why so many wires? *chuckling*
AW it's so many wires....
OH HO HO HO It's so cute...
OH not at all...that's so weird..
Ok so, there's go to be something here because this one, I see wires for feet and we kind of saw it in the reflection.
So this is like the- this is the version of the Endoskeleton.
Uh- it's like, the other animatronics were- had Endoskeletons and that's what they were
and they had shells, so these ones, when they get scooped, they get this stuff scooped out of them
and that's apparently what happens there.
And in the animatronics- or-uh in the spring trap section, this animatronic was on the right.
Because it had to be looking at Ballora- it had to be pulled over to the left to be scooped- you know how it was.
So, you were looking at this from this angle which meant you were on the right side of the room.
So there's something over there.
Oh and Freddy. Oh Freddy, y-you've looked better Freddy.
Ooohhhhhh...!!! Okay. SEE!?!? WHAT'S IN THERE!?!?
WHAT'S IN THE PRIVATE ROOM!?!
So what happens- *gasp* What happens if when you're walking through, you go right?
Like, instead of going left. Every time she says left you go forward and right instead?
What if you do that? What if that happens? That's an interesting thing, okay.
Imma try that.
Let's- let's do that- Oh man. O.o Ew...
That's not a blueprint! That's just horrifying!!
Okay, so um I just noticed something. There's a key pad right here.
And Baby gave a very specific string of numbers. I can't remember what it was.
It was seven *beep* one seven *beep* *Elevator stops* Something something something something.
*music plays* But there's a key pad there so that can't be entirely-
-out of the question to try to input that number.
There's another key pad right here so maybe I've gotta input them on all (light buzzes) the key pads? Or something?
I dunno Maybe. but there's-
[Hand Unit] Great, now let's check on Funtime Foxy.
[Mark] There's gotta be a reason there's keypads, right?
There's gotta be a reason.
[Hand Unit] Circus Baby Has been Deactivated
[Mark] Oh!! WAIT A MINUTE!!! WAIT A MINUTE!!       [Hand Unit] For an unknown reason. It's your job to make sure
[Hand Unit] She is structurally stable and                                                                [Mark] Hello!!
and secure to the conveyor
[Mark] Hi.....
[Hand Unit] our technicians will take it from there                                            [Mark] *gasps*  *static*
Oh... I see it now. How did I not see that? HOW DID I NOT SEE THAT!?!?
[Baby] Eight
[Mark] Ohh... (beep) different.
[Baby] Six
*silence*
[Mark] Heey!!
I was- Okay. I-is the code random!?!
Or is that- just- Or is it two separate codes? It might be- It might be just random numbers. Okay
[Baby] Go forward and left.
*Long silence*
*jumpscare* Mark: Ohh!! Okay... that DIDN'T WORK!! That was NOT correct!!
Okay, so....        there's gotta be- okay. There's gotta be something else. I'm exploring a lot of different options here.
I don't think I'm gonna get it in THIS episode. I'm gonna try to uh-  to figure this out: But I'm gonna do ONE MORE THING!!
I'm gonna try to get to the mini game now which just involves me dying.
And then I'm gonna figure a way to beat it. And I'm gonna see if you can like stack the cupcakes together.
There we go!! I got the game, so... it's gotta be something to do with this game, right?
So... there's a way-  maybe to ration out the uh-
*collects cupcakes*
the freakin' things.
There's gotta be a way. Okay, so.. one... two.......okay....? Kay...
S-so they're- they're fed. So....
Maybe it's like using the right ones in the right location?
Cause like this triplet here can be taken care of by the green one.
Oh shit. God dammit. Wha-
Okay so... the shotgun blast.....
This kid needs three I think is what it is.
God dammit.
Aww... fudge.... FUUUDDDGGGGEEE!!!! Fudgee fudge fu-fu-fu- fudge fudge fudge fuuuddggee fuudddggggeeee fuuuuudddgggggeeee!!!
There is no way that is gonna work. It is a load of bullshit!! And I hate it a lot!!!
God dammit, okay so...
So I ALMOST got all of them but it's just like-
It's like I didn't get all of them. I think there might be a way if I jump OVER the cupcake
and get to and come back for the triple one. And then... ahh man.... I gotta get two and the kid and then three and the shotgun.
*groans* Its just convoluted.
It might be possible, It MIGHT be possible.
[Baby] You must follow my instructions in Funtime Auditorium.
*door opening or closing*  Go forward. *Foot steps*
[Female Robotic Voice] Access denied. [Mark] OH!!!  *Jumpscare*
HI!! WHAT WAS THAT!?!? OH!!! OOHHH!!!
Oh, okay, I got denied, but that's okay!! That's progress!! Holy shit! I haven't been able to do ANYTHING!!
Oh...
So I made a mistake before. I-I- before
Oh, I thought I couldn't do that.
I went forward and THEN forward and right. I just needed to go forward and right  IMMEDIATELY after you go out that door
You hit W, and D immediately and bank for that but it said "Access Denied" So there's something I need *banging*
Somewhere in the game to get through that Private Room. I still think it has to do with the Mini Game.
But I need to find a better way to DIE, that sounds horrible, but I need to find a better way to DIE, repeatedly
So that I can get the Mini game. If Foxy was here, in that room it would make it so much easier
but I do not have that right now. So...
I've been trying for a while, so I think I'm out of time for this episode here but is progress. So you need something
in the game. I believe there's gotta be a way to get the cupcakes to every kid in the game, like-
I'm pretty sure it has to do with um- using like- uh- the cupcakes in the right place.
Where there's staggered ones, you get those, where there's ones alone, you get those.
Where there's spread ones, you get those. Like, there's an option to do it, because you get four blue ones.
And there's like-  two spread zones with three of them and you can DEFINITELY hit those.
There's three green ones and there's definitely lines of guys in a row that you can definitely hit.
So there are options to do that you just have to find the right one and then jump OVER the cupcakes so that you run over
and get the right ones at the right times to do everything you need to do FIRST!!
Before you get all the cupcakes so I don't know how long that's gonna take so I'm gonna take care of that in the episode.
THANK YOU, everybody so much for watching. That is my hypothesis. Let me know if there's anything
I should do differently before I do the next videos. So as soon as this one goes up, write down in the comments bellow
If there's anything else you think I should do, but I think I'm on the right track here, I just need  more time to get it done.
So Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-Bye!!
(Bye Markimoo!)
(His amazing horror outro music)